gimme hugs hugs hugs and drugs
Felipe fill the huggie bear bro on the
way here bro
I just want to tell you guys that I was
just talking to some cops on our side
there are no suckers what we're doing is
right we're in them now we got Colorado
we got Michigan Vermont and now we're
gonna have it legal here are those the
right states yeah oh no man okay okay
man okay yeah this guy's got it he's
keepin it real oh I'm so sorry
oh why did I have a security that's
secret that's a secret security monitor
don't trust you guys you're less he
knows sometimes you're in gangs
because sometimes you kill people that's
[ __ ]
I don't like that I don't like that are
you a u-boat you're you're so Mexican it
yeah please come on
but are you Mexican no so that they they
should have the security camera look at
the secret security camera it's just no
okay I didn't come here to buy anything
I just came here to support you old and
then what you'd go what we do we do
together and I'm barb Marley bar look
that's them but that's morally right no
look look look a little closer because
Marley isn't all of us so it is a Bob
Marley Marley well you guys I didn't
come here to buy anything I just want to
support what we're doing the positive
vibes more ir guys I would give you
another hug but I think I hurt my rib
well I was a little wasted on the babe
and man so my ribs are hurting but right
now you're gonna work out here you do it
right here thank you sir
I heard of people giving you advice but
after they sucked in the energy I'm
gonna smell like patchouli oil for three
months they have many kind of smart like
Domino's Pizza I know hey did he just
get us
he just got us well we have a camera
wait a second we have no cameras